I did a group session in one on one with Megan yesterday and lots of emotional work.
Also was on the right for about three hours while on the Zoom call with her.
I felt good when I woke up this morning but after my coffee, I had a lot of crampied
and blood in the stool.
The blood is mucusy and stringy, if that makes sense.
Still having crampied this afternoon feels like dry heaves and stomach or colon.
I just finished up my third row of bed is all four days on three days off and I grew back
to five days on, two days on yesterday.
What if this could be an emotional release or a detox reaction, could, those are possible
for sure.
Don't rule out that you might have a little bug or something too, maybe you got a little
flu or something too.
So it goes back to, you know, I know we're not feeling good, we always, you know, was
quite anything to our disease, but I have to remember that we could have other things going
on too.
I'd definitely be taking, you know, more immune stimulants or something like that, getting
your rest, you know, drinking some tea, just taking it easy, trying to treat it as if you
have something that you need to take care of yourself with on this, like some, but
um, maybe I don't know, you know, Mac, so this person, one-on-one session with Megan, they're
talking about, yeah, Mac then, Zell, who does emotional help with emotional clearing and dealing
with deep emotional, emotional root causes, who we refer people to, I'm sure it certainly
could be tied to that too.
Is it okay to do coffee enemas while I am taking eyebrows or should I do them on my seven
day break?
Um, I have been doing them three days a week.
I would say you could continue to take coffee, do coffee enemas while doing eyebrows, I don't
think there's an issue there.
Do I have to wait a few days after getting my Zelletta and basil, basil next before going to
the sun?
I don't know, I think it'd be good to wait 24 hours, but I don't think you need to wait,
you know, more than that.
Can you tell me if burberry would be, would affect the benefit of me if so, how much?
So for those who've listened to me very long, I'm a huge fan of burberry.
Burberry has, you know, so many health benefits, even if you don't have, you know, cancer, um,
burberry is one of the best killers of H. Pylori, which has, has at least a huge comorbidity
with anybody with cancer, um, anybody with heart disease, you have to kind of expect that
you have H. Pylori issues.
So burberry is a huge killer of H. Pylori, burberry is a great immune stimulator, there's tons of
articles on burberry and cancer, there's also, um, tons of information of burberry,
lowering blood sugar.
So the burberry can be great to lower blood sugar, which could help cut off the fuel source
of the cancer as well.
So burberry is a huge fan of it.
I use the burberry clear and the reason why we have the burberry clear as the private label
is it also has awful paying gas at it, which is such a great, um, antioxidant.
So, um, burberry clear taking, you know, two to three a day would be appropriate, it's just
a great product for so many things.